Transcriptor: Valentina Sosa
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En un mundo donde todo está resuelto
la creatividad da pereza.
¿Para qué exponerme al error,
a la frustración, a la humillación,
si tengo la solución
a un clic de distancia?
Trabajo como creativa publicitaria
en Estados Unidos
y hace años que me vengo planteando
a la creatividad
no solamente como una profesión,
sino como una opción de vida.
Nací en Uruguay, donde la creatividad
surge en pos de resolver un problema.
Atamos con alambre.
Cuando hay hambre, no hay pan duro.
Son dos frases que reflejan la inventiva
y el ingenio sudamericano
y que simplemente reflejan esa dialéctica
entre las ansias de progreso
y la falta de recursos.
Esto nos hace extremadamente valiosos
en el extranjero
porque nos ayuda a acelerar procesos,
de organizaciones burocráticas
que se estancan.
Se estancan en ese proceso.
En 2014 me mudé a Vietnam y me di cuenta
de que la génesis del proceso creativo
era bastante similar a la sudamericana.
Muchos problemas, pocos recursos
y mayor ingenio.
Un ejemplo concreto y al pie
es el característico gorro cónico
del sudeste asiático.
Ese gorro no solamente es de fácil acceso
y sumamente económico,
sino que también resuelve
dos problemas en uno.
No solamente cuida del sol,
sino que también es impermeable.
En el 2015 me mudé a Suecia
para hacer mi maestría
y la concepción de la creatividad
era completamente diferente.
En una sociedad donde todas
las necesidades están resueltas,
donde ya le diste vuelta a todas
las plataformas de streaming,
tenés hijos y estás todo bien,
el aburrimiento se torna
mi amigo recurrente.
Y allí, desde el ocio,
de repente, empezás a ver una silla
que tiene cuatro patas
pero la pensás con tres.
Y así surgen cosas como Ikea.
Luego, en el 2016, tuve la oportunidad
de volver a Singapur
y en esta oportunidad, Asia
me sorprendió desde otra manera,
porque la creatividad que descubrí allí
era una creatividad hecha a demanda,
donde la financiación de una idea
muchas veces era más fuerte que su fin,
y donde realmente reflejaba
aquello que dice McLuhan
donde el medio es el mensaje.
Y si concilio las diferentes partes
de tener una idea, tener recursos,
y tener talento, puedo hacer
cosas geniales
como un hotel de tres torres
en forma de barco
en una marina artificial
en el medio de la ciudad.
Actualmente vivo en Nueva York, una de las
mecas de la creatividad y hoy por hoy,
la agenda creativa está marcada
por la búsqueda del propósito.
Es decir, que una buena idea es tal
si genera bienestar en el mundo,
si ayuda a generar conciencia
sobre determinado tema
o si simplemente promueve una buena causa.
Y a pesar de estar en las trincheras
de la creatividad
la inspiración cuesta.
Cuesta horrores, porque a la creatividad
se la lleva la intrepidez del día a día,
la marchita la productividad,
se prostituye con la financiación.
Y en esta sociedad la creatividad
se ve agotada y limitada
porque en pos de generar algo nuevo,
innovador, único,
la deshumanizamos.
La volvemos estéril en nombre
de lo políticamente correcto
y simplemente nos importa más
el mayor retorno de inversión
o agradar a una mayor audiencia.
Entonces uno se siente realmente miserable
porque está en las óptimas condiciones
para generar lo mejor
y aun así no importa si genera propósito,
si genera conciencia, si soluciona
un problema o si mata el aburrimiento.
Nunca, pero nunca es suficiente.
Un buen día te despertás
y estás frustrado.
Y es una frustración
que te paraliza por completo,
que te entumece
y que te interpela.
Y te interpela y te grita y te mira
a los ojos y te dice con mayúsculas:
¿Y AHORA QUÉ VAS A HACER?
¿Qué vas a hacer?
Si bien me sigo preguntando
y tratando de buscar esa respuesta,
lo único que sé es que necesito
sentir para poder crear.
Y si mi sentimiento es frustración,
en esa misma frustración
debo de encontrarla, debo
de encontrar esa respuesta.
La única manera de emanciparme
a este letargo es ser vulnerable,
es aceptar que ya no tengo control,
es aceptar que estoy frustrada,
amigarme con los miedos
y tratar de transformar esos “no”,
esos “no” en posibilidades, en “síes”,
en reivindicar la posibilidad
de lo distinto, de lo diferente,
de lo que me dijeron que no y de patear
el tablero y de pensar diferente.
Por eso podemos decir que el acto creativo
es un acto completamente sedicioso,
peligroso, riesgoso, que incomoda,
que no le gusta a mucha gente.
Y en definitiva, no queda otra
que animarse
y pensar que bueno, si esto ya es no,
lo único que queda es el sí.
Entonces adueñarnos de ese “sí“,
de pensar,
de creer que va a salir todo bien,
porque cuando yo utilizo la palabra
“yo creo” usamos dos verbos en uno:
creo de crear y creo de creer.
Entonces es prácticamente que
un acto divino, un acto de fe,
que no tengo ni idea del resultado
pero aun así va a ser satisfactorio,
porque va a estar más alineado
con mi propósito, con lo que necesito.
Y no simplemente sigo recetas.
Por eso también podemos decir que
la creatividad es un acto político.
O sea, nos interpela de forma tal que
tenemos que realmente reinventarnos
todos los días para pelear
esos pequeños “no”.
Y ante esta frustración
tenemos dos opciones:
o creamos y creemos
y nos exponemos y somos vulnerables
y aceptamos ese riesgo,
o nos quedamos en el molde,
nos quedamos quietitos y, bueno,
aceptamos lo que venga.
Y decimos “esto no está tan mal”.
Y, simplemente, nos conformamos
y compramos esos espejismos
de inspiración e innovación.
Yo creo que este camino y esta opción
están a la mano de cualquiera
que se anime a transitarla, a transitar
este camino engorroso y de frustración
y bastante, bastante jodido.
Está a la mano de cualquiera
que se anime a transitarla,
independientemente del
continente en el que viva,
o de la génesis de la creatividad
que su sociedad le indique
o le haya sido oriunda.
Porque en esta sociedad de productividad
y de utilitarismo
nos olvidamos del verdadero
motor de la creatividad
que es esa frustración, es ese dolor,
es ese riesgo, es esa duda.
Entonces, una vez que nos
animamos a cuestionarnos
y que nos adueñamos de esa frustración,
la duda ya no nos interpela tanto,
el miedo asusta un poco menos
y la certeza de lo auténtico
nos hace un poquito más libres.
Defendamos esa libertad,
esa libertad a capa y espada,
como la mejor página en blanco
que podemos tener.
Y, en definitiva, sintamos
ese cosquilleo interior
que nos dice que le ganamos
un poquito a la incertidumbre
y que, simplemente, estamos a una idea
de algo extraordinario.
Muchas gracias.